It's great to welcome to the program today.
Cory Doctorow, who is the author of two new
books, How to Destroy Surveillance Capitalism
Also Attack Surface.
The third installment in The New York Times,
best selling Little Brothers series. Corey,
so great to have you on today.
It's my pleasure. Thank you for having me
on.
So to start with, we've talked about surveillance
capitalism on the program before. But as someone
who's who's really written a lot about this,
how do you explain the concept to someone
who may not be familiar with it?
Well, it should be noted that I don't agree
with majority criticism of surveillance capitalism.
Yes. I think that the majority criticism goes
basically Google invented a mind control rate
to sell you efficient spinner. And then Robert
Mercer used it to make your uncle racist.
And I think that, you know, this gives Google
way too much credit because big tech, too
much credit. The history is littered with
people who claim that they could influence
us with technology. And mostly what they do
is influence their potential customers, like
advertisers to give them a lot of money, but
then under deliver. I think there's every
indication that that's what Google and Facebook
and other ad tech companies are doing, which
is not to say that they aren't spying on us
like crazy. They are. And it's not to say
that that's not harmful. It's super is. And
it's and it's not to say that they don't distort
our discourse. They do. But they do so because
they're monopolists and monopolies get to
subvert the regulatory process so they can
do dangerous things like over surveillance
and over retention of data. And then, you
know, if there's only one place we go to ask
questions, the answer that they give us matters
a lot to what we believe, but not because
they have a mind control ray, just because
they've become a canonical source.
So for people who have read about surveillance
capitalism, often it's Shoshana's Xbox work
that that folks may be maybe familiar with.
So correct me if I'm wrong, and I'm glad for
you to kind of go into this. It seems as though
maybe you you believe that Shoshana is correctly
identifying some of the characteristics, but
the conclusions that she comes to are not
necessarily your conclusions.
Yes. So I think that Zubov really does believe
that machine learning allows us allows tech
companies to manipulate us to take away what
she calls our right to the future tense, right.
The right to to be able to decide for ourselves
what we'll do in the future. And I think that
that's not true of machine learning, but it's
totally true of Monopoly. Right. If all of
your friends are corralled on Facebook, then
Facebook can tell you with a high degree of
accuracy that you're gonna have to stay on
Facebook to talk to them. And, you know, a
way to maybe visualize the difference between
our points of view is that she thinks that
traditional ProComp competition remedies like
breaking the companies up or opening them
up to interoperability or anything else that
we might do to reduce their power will just
produce like hundreds of pipsqueaks, each
of them with their own mind control. Right.
And we won't even be able to keep track of
them and how they're using them. So imagine
that there was a comet headed towards Earth
and you had someone who said, no, no, no,
we can't try and break the comet up. If we
do, it'll turn into a million meteors and
they'll just smash every city on earth. We
have to we have to steer the comet. And that's
what she thinks, right? She thinks we need
to tame the companies by telling them what
they can and can't do. Putting them under
tighter control and so on. And I just don't
think you can put them under control for so
long as they have been topolice because they
have so much excess money from being monopolists
and they're so concentrated that they can
agree on how to spend that money that they
can end up steering their own course. You
know, people look at that picture of the tech
leaders with Donald Trump in 2016 at the top
of Trump Tower on that table meeting with
them. And they go like, how can Tim Cook and
all these other self-described bastions of
liberalism meet with Donald Trump? That's
a fair question. But a better one is how is
it that everyone who runs tech fits around
a single table that that should be even more
alarming?
And so when you talk about the how the the
monopoly aspect is a big piece of why the
status quo is as it is. Let's talk through
what it would look like if that if that weren't
the case, because I could imagine that if
instead of Facebook, Google, Amazon, you know,
pick, pick, pick the five and say instead
there's 10 in each instead of each of the
five, I could imagine, well, if everybody
is more spread out rather than on one platform,
it's harder to be as accurately predictive
about how people are going to be behaving
online because you've only got a fraction
of the data rather than than a huge portion
of it. At the same time, there's the money
argument, which is if you have 50 players
instead of five, no one of them is going to
be so well-funded that maybe they could it.
So how how much of it is is the financial
piece? How much of it is the sort of network
effect of everybody being on a few platforms?
Well, let's talk about network effects, because
historically network effects for tech were
not as durable as they are in other areas
like, say, railroads, right. Network effects
and railroads are super powerful. Has once
you've got the rails, everyone's got to use
them. And no one wants to build a second set
of rails next to your rails.
Right. But if you're say IBM and you have
this giant printer division called Lexmark
and you have the network effects of of having
this huge customer base and you then decide
to extract high rents for your toner. Right.
The carbon that you put into them and use
a security chip to make sure no one puts their
own carbon in a carbon is obviously a very
abundant element where we're struggling to
deal with an overabundance of carbon. Not
hard to get all the carbon you need. So along
comes a a little Taiwanese company called
Static Controls. And they use the network
effect like judo, because they say, hey, look,
IBM has created this huge market of people
who bought subsidized printers. We can sell
them cheap toner. They clone IBM's chip. Right.
They make an interoperable chip and now they
own Lexmark. They bought Lexmark from IBM.
Or if you're Apple and you're being outcompeted
by Microsoft in the enterprise because Microsoft
deliberately breaks compatibility between
Microsoft Office for the Mac and Microsoft
Office for Windows, you can just say, well,
to heck with Microsoft. We're just going to
reverse engineer how Microsoft Office works
and release the Iwerks Sweet pages and numbers
and keynote so that Mac users can just interoperate
with Windows users. So what I think is that
when people have problems with the way that
tech works and those problems can be the result
of tech trying to do something harmful to
them, like manipulate them or can just be
the result of tech not considering their uses.
Right.
You know that the technology that we've all
encountered that assumes that you've always
got a reliable Internet connection has proved
a lot less reliable than we hoped it would.
Now that we're all stuck at home and sharing
our Internet with all of our neighbors all
day long, you get to modify it or you get
to find someone to modify or someone identifies
you as a market and modifies that tech so
that it suits your needs and not the needs
of the shareholders, the people who made it
in the first place. And that in that world,
the equilibrium we get is companies competing
to see how happy they can make you, not companies
competing to see how tightly they can control
your actions in the future so that you're
stuck with them.
I want to continue down this path, but one
sort of small 10 tangential issue I'm curious
to get your thoughts about, as I was recently
speaking to someone in the tech space who
said, you know, with a lot of the pick pick
some niche area where there is like one one
big player, if you heard it all of a sudden,
get 10 players in that same space, in all
likelihood, they'd all be using Amazon Web
Services. And so Jeff Bezos basically could
still flip one switch and shut all 10 of them
down. That that's a very practical concern.
But it's a real one, isn't it?
It certainly is. And that's why, you know,
traditional antimonopoly remedies are include
something called structural separation, which
was in the congressional report that was released
this week as well. And structural separation
starts with things like railroads being banned
from owning coal companies or freight companies
where they own the people that they haul freight
for or they own businesses that compete with
the people that they haul freight for. And
you could imagine a structural separation
regime for Amazon where they say you can be
a platform or you can use the platform, but
you can't compete with the users of the platform
if you own the platform. That's like the casino
boss coming down and gambling at the table
opposite you. And the croupier knows that
if if the casino boss loses, the croupier
loses their job, too. Right. We want we want
a level playing field there. And I want to
stress that there's like a little nuance here,
because although I think the monopolies that
tech has created are the same mediocre as
sociopathic bullying tactics that we saw with
coal and that we saw with electricity that
we see today with light beer and with logistics
and and so many other industries that it becomes
super concentrated. Pro-Wrestling is down
to one league. Right. That there is one way
in which tech is very different. And it is
this compatability idea that that making a
pro wrestling league that can interact with
other pro wrestling leagues seamlessly is
hard. Making a version of Office for the Mac
that can read and write Office for Windows
turned out to be pretty straightforward. And
the history of technology is filled with these
companies that had dominance like Amazon and
saw that dominance taken away from them because
of inter operators, because of competitive
compatibility, making new things that plug
into old things, even though the people who
made those old things don't want you to.
And you're eating their lunch by doing so
to pick one of the things you mention to dig
into a little deeper. Our data, the data about
us, about our activities and big tech, having
that data, using the data to market to us
or through tracking pixels, allowing third
parties to target us in very specific ways.
There's a pattern of. Plea of ideas about
how and why this is bad. Can you focus in
again with your background in writing science
fiction as well and having no shortage of
connection to dystopian futures and near futures
and so on? What are the real concerns there
about big tech having our data? Which ones
maybe are overblown in your mind?
So I want to dig into this, but it is like
a technical, uncomplicated issue. So I'm just
gonna give you like a top line here. Yeah.
When we release data or when we harvest data
and hold it and think about the risk of it
being released nonconsensual, we like it leaking
or being hacked from us or what have you.
We try to anticipate the risks from that data
being released. And when we give data to companies,
we try to anticipate those risks. What could
they do with X and Y and Z? X and Y and Z
on their own aren't a big deal. So the NHS
in the UK, where I used to live, did a controlled
data release of prescribing data, longitudinal
prescribing data, which is a super useful
thing to have so that, you know, they they
gave each patient a random identifier and
then they said witchdoctor prescribe which
meds to that person on what day in which hospital.
And we could see over there that through that
data set, you could see, you know, like, is
there a risk if they put if your doctor puts
you on statins, that you'll then have to go
on tricyclic antidepressants or sending stuff
like that? That is hard to see in individual
cases or in studies, but the data might reveal.
So that's felt like a safe bet. You know,
if you ask me to review that data release,
I would have said I can't see any real risk
in this release. But then a taxi company had
a breach and that taxi company was widely
used by patients who went to hospitals for
prescriptions. And so now you can see the
person who went from David Pakman house to
this hospital to get these tricyclic anti-depressants
or hormones that are given to people who are
undergoing gender transition or some other
very sensitive prescribing data that correlates
exactly with David going back and forth to
the hospital. So in order to understand the
risks of a data harvesting, a data release
or giving your data to someone, you have to
be able to anticipate all the other data that
might be collected and released in the future.
That's a very hard thing to be able to understand.
And so the risk is effectively infinite. Right.
It's it's it is a an unquantifiable risk that
happens when we gather and create large datasets.
And the lesson of history is that if you collect
data, it will probably breach. And if you
retain it long enough, it will absolutely
breach. I mean, the thing I always tell firms
when they asked me about this is if the NSA
couldn't stop Snowden from leaking their documents.
Right. What makes you think that you're going
to be able to stop someone from leaking
your documents?
We will pause our conversation there with
Cory Doctorow and go to
a break on
the podcast, radio and television program,
my full conversation with Corey.
And it
is fascinating so far. We'll be
on our YouTube channel at YouTube.
Dot com slash